hello everyone i just started the live
stream and share the link in the chat so
for those who
miss out on the meeting in between can
refer the link later
we will be starting in more two minutes
thank you for joining
as you are joining the session please
make sure that you keep your microphones
on mute
hello everyone i would like to welcome
you all to today's webinar on
bioinformatics research
fellowship my name is sunalika ray
and i am the omixlogic community manager
i am responsible for daily interaction
with thousands of
users that are a part of a
bioinformatics community
managed by pine biotech
omixlogic is an international program
that is running
in five different regions with over 10
000 users around the world
and due to this fast growth our team is
working with local
and racial coordinators that are helping
refine local
program logistics and leverage our
online training resources
adapting them to the needs of students
and researchers around the world
in today's webinar we will focus on the
research fellowship program
explain the research fellowship program
discuss the fellowship that is
ongoing batches introduce the new dates
starting in july and in the fall
and also discuss about the omics
research symposium details with
confirmed speakers
price categories and topics on how to
submit the project on loan
and what makes a project stand out the
ways to get prizes or recognition
and answer the questions in our current
batches
which are scheduled to be completed by
the end of the august
we have over 50 participants from india
africa
us peru mexico and other countries
some of the fellows went on to join our
campus ambassador program
and others as interns working for the
company
all of them got the opportunity to learn
develop independent project proposals
participate in mentorship sessions and
often times present their projects in
front of a large audience
and get exposure for their achievements
now i would like to welcome our
research intern navadhawa to share her
experience with us
over to you
sorry navia we can't hear you
i think you need to make her a co-host
okay i think she got disconnected uh
i would like to pass it on to our ceo
elia brodsky to share about the program
and then we would hear from navya thank
you
all right thank you very much sonalika
and welcome everyone to this webinar i'm
excited to see all of you join today
and hopefully after today's webinar
you'll be able to clearly understand
what this program is designed to do how
it can help you
and answer all of your questions that
i'm sure you have
about the program before i start let me
briefly introduce to you
what we are all about so our company
name is called pine biotech
we're a biotechnology company located in
the us in new orleans in louisiana
but we are a technology transfer company
that stems out of university of haifa
specifically the center
for bioinformatics called the tower
bioinformatics research center
the center was started to make
bioinformatics more accessible
design algorithms as well as make them
useful for people that do not have
extensive bioinformatics background and
expertise
and what we've identified as a team is
that there is a
growing need in training individuals to
be effective at utilizing
the wide range of bioinformatics tools
and apply them in a meaningful way to
research
challenges that are pressing in the area
of biomedical research
agriculture and biotechnology and so as
a result in 2017 we started a program
that up till date has over 15 000
participants from around the world
we have a lot of content that we have
refined with the help of many different
curriculum reviewers and work together
with a number of
highly specialized universities around
the world
organizations that are training the next
generation of bioinformaticians
and working with statewide and
country-wide
organizations that are designed to help
elevate the level of biomedical research
around the country
including the louisiana biomedical
research network
including our partners in different high
schools colleges
research labs and industry and so
as a result we have really identified
these three pillars
of our program which is access to big
data in a meaningful way so
solving the problem of computational
resources so that
anyone from the comfort of their home
can
utilize complex tools apply them to big
data and get meaningful insights
the second aspect is mentorship it's not
easy from the comfort of your home
to really know what you're doing and so
that's why we brought in
a number of experienced and highly
qualified mentors that are ready to
assist
anyone go from knowing about
bioinformatics
to actually applying bioinformatics and
the third pillar is obviously training
so we provide
resources that are making the
computational background the algorithmic
component
training in coding and different
elements of
bioinformatics as well as biology and
biomedicine and biotechnology how do you
apply
data science to these challenges so we
merge those together
in our omics logic curriculum so as
i mentioned this is what we will focus
on in
today's webinar number one we will
explain
what is the research fellowship program
and how you can benefit from this
program so
the program is a very specialized
program
this is not like other training
opportunities that you will find online
it's a research focused program so i
will talk about that and what makes this
program
unique number two we will talk a little
bit about the ongoing batches so we have
over 50 students as sonic already
mentioned
and what are the new dates to start in
july as well as in the fall of 2021
and so that you will be in you will have
a clear understanding of
the schedule why did we design the
program to be finished by
august and then what are some of the new
batch opportunities that will be coming
up
we will introduce our omics research
symposium that symposium is an
opportunity for you
to demonstrate your work on different
types of projects
learn from experts identify industry
opportunities
how you can get into internships with
companies
fellowships in different labs and also
how you can
get a job in this industry but also
we'll introduce you to
masters and phd programs around the
country in the us
but also available for international
students and discuss how you can join
those
so we'll have speakers that represent
those uh programs and i'll talk about
that
and then we will have prizes for best
categories
of projects so if you're already in
bioinformatics you're learning
bioinformatics
you think that you have a great project
you should join
and apply for a prize and so we will
discuss what those prices are what the
categories of prices are
and how you can register for that then
we will briefly talk about how to submit
the project on comics logic learn so
we'll go through the interface and kind
of show you what are the steps to submit
that
and we'll hear from students in a
research fellow who has done that
recently
and then we will have some time for q a
so before we begin
uh so narika let's launch the first poll
just to kind of learn about the
participants in today's session
thank you elia i just launched the poll
and my first question is what is your
level of education
are you from high school or are you an
undergraduate graduate post graduate or
a phd fellow or a postdoctorate
and my second question is what are your
research interests
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
data science
machine learning agribioinformatics
neurosciences
or do you like bioinformatics using r
and python
genomics transcriptomics and
metagenomics
and my last question is when are you
planning to join the research fellowship
program
immediately or in the fall or in the
next six to 12 months or are you not
planning to join now
thank you i would be ending the poll in
in more 30 seconds
all right excellent so we have about 50
of the people have
voted already okay so
again this is important for us to
understand uh
to explain better how the different
types of resources that we have and the
different opportunities that we will
plan for the research symposium can help
you
get the most out of this program all
right great so we have 70 percent
uh have completed the poll uh
okay excellent thank you for those that
are completing still
all right eighty percent great
okay so i think we are wrapping up umika
maybe you could tell us briefly um
towards the end
what are the outcomes of the program
thank you so much all right
okay so we will share the results
towards the end
in the meantime let me briefly introduce
uh what is the research fellowship
program
and how it works so
practically speaking how it works so the
research fellowship program is unique
because it's really designed to offer
you a
supportive community with very practical
outcomes
and so you can see here some examples of
poster presentations
about the different types of programs as
well as some of the projects that have
been submitted
individually or as group projects
and so to help facilitate the process
of going from learning bioinformatics to
actually applying bioinformatics to big
data and getting results
we designed this kind of a process
that helps anyone without previous
practical knowledge of bioinformatics if
you've known about bioinformatics you
understand what it is you can get
started
and then get all the way to this outcome
right so the question is how
and the way we did it is we started
developing
exemplar projects from peer-reviewed
papers
that cover a variety of topics including
epigenetic regulation of asthma or
precision medicine using cell line
models and artificial intelligence
how to apply deep sequencing
technologies to understand viral
replication
how to study the changing uh landscape
of our um of the ecology and understand
how we can intervene
how to understand the immune responses
in cancer
how to study the microbiome of
individuals that are scattered around
the world and understand what factors
are affecting the microbiome
how to study these animal
patient-derived
xenograft models or pdx models where you
can study
cancer coming from a human in an animal
model
how to apply the understanding of big
data to
tcga the cancer genome atlas that
represents thousands of patients from
different types of cancers
how to apply bioinformatics and
biotechnology
and understand the production of
biologics including vaccines and
different kinds of
large proteins that are used for
treatment of specific diseases
or even how to apply analysis of
transatomic data to understand
the crop drought stress and resistance
and different
cultivars of potato how to understand
the complex gene regulation
in neurodegenerative diseases or
understand outbreaks of infectious
pandemics like the ebola outbreak of
2014-2016
but the range of topics doesn't end
there and so that's why
we also provide you with an opportunity
to start from scratch and design
a project that is completely
individually picked by you
so we have a system that can help you
find a topic understand what type of
data
could be used to study that topic and
how to ask a specific
tech a specific technical question that
could be answered with data analysis
and then how to go through the process
of designing a research project
on your own in groups and with the help
of
a mentor so the way this works
is that we have a program that is
designed to
help you understand through the
introduction
evaluate your progress through practice
and then start applying these different
analysis skills to a data set
of your own and along the way interact
with our community through weekly
progress reports
on slack as we interact with each other
and have a whole community that can
discuss a variety of topics
but also through access to mentorship
and i will talk about that in just a few
moments
but first let's talk about the
introduction so as a part of getting you
started it's important to get
a broad perspective widen your horizon
and understand the application of
bioinformatics to big data that is
widely available and that includes
coursework that you can complete
asynchronously on the introduction
on and on different types of omics
technologies genomics
transcriptomics metagenomics epigenomics
and gain practical skills in data
science including
machine learning statistical analysis
coding in r and python
as well as fair practices to
make your analysis reproducible which is
a critical
important skill to have if you are going
into research or
even if you're going into industry
ultimately
after that you get an opportunity to
use our omixlogic portal to develop
and submit your project and get feedback
along the way and so the process that
you have is that first of all you have
to
earn a certain number of points
you have to update your profile and
really create a profile that you can
share
and then go through these steps to start
submitting a project
and so when you submit that project you
can actually
upload all of the information that is
needed
and then complete your profile um adding
some information about your background
adding social media links to your
linkedin or potentially to org id
and really being ready for submitting a
project
and sharing it with the world and so
after you go through that
you will also get access to a whole
course
on how to submit a project that is
impactful and that will be evaluated by
our
experts from the bioinformatics
community what you gain out of this
process
is ability to understand
how others have applied bioinformatics
to different types of studies through
literature review you get to become an
investigator
which is what people do in research but
also in industry they
know how to ask questions and answer
those questions with data
and also you get the ability to write
and prepare the project for the
presentation
so that you get a good result you get an
impactful presentation that you can
share
with experts in the field the way that
this happens
is through a defined series of steps
first
by identifying a competitive topic in an
area of research that others are
interested in
number two by finding data sets which
you will get guidance on
number three to summarize your data and
prepare
a summary of what does the metadata
describe about the data that you found
conducting
exploratory analysis then doing in-depth
analysis biological interpretation
and then you start interaction with your
mentor the peers and
experts and so that's where the
community comes in so all throughout
this process we have
weekly sessions and at the end once
you've gotten the feedback from the
mentor the experts and the community
you actually start working on your
project presentation so that project
presentation
also follows a number of defined steps
that everybody follows both in research
and
in your university studies right you
have to essentially build a project that
will describe
what have you done what are the findings
and what is the significance of those
findings for the field that you are in
whether it's data science whether it is
neuroscience
precision medicine agriculture
biotechnology etc
the field needs to know why they should
be paying attention to your project
and how does your analysis contribute to
answering
some of the gaps in current research or
answering questions about
how to utilize methods to address gaps
that will come
in the future and so i think that this
program is unique because it really
provides us with
unique outcomes that are guaranteed
so what are some of the guaranteed
outcomes number one
you will definitely learn about the
challenges and the opportunities
in bioinformatics as a whole so in many
cases when we talk to students
that are either undergraduate or in
graduate master degree programs
they have a theoretical understanding of
bioinformatics but they don't understand
how they can
apply bioinformatics to address a
specific challenge
or whether what they are doing is going
to be meaningful and needed
in a particular field number two many
don't have the practical training to be
able to independently work with data
sets and so that's where training and
skill development comes in
but it's only one part of the program
not the full program
number three you can work on independent
or group research projects so you can
really work on a project
that you found a data set that you're
interested in or even
join the program before you identify a
data set and a question
and learn how to develop a question and
start finding that data set
but you can also work in groups so as we
mentioned we have about 50 people in the
different batches we have three
different batches
and also some other batches for high
school students that are
later in the day in the us and so that's
when you can
collaborate with others and learn how to
work together as a team
solving these interdisciplinary problems
then finally
some most ambitious people will go for a
poster presentation or even a research
publication and so
in a few minutes i will introduce you to
some of these outcomes
with practical examples who has done
this
so let's talk briefly about the specific
questions that we've had so number one
can this program be used for the
requirement of a university internship
the answer is yes and by the way right
now you're welcome to write any other
questions that you have
and i see that some of you are doing it
but i will address
all of these questions that you're
asking in the next few slides
so again number one can this program be
used for a requirement for university
internship
yes we have a number of image
university participants and participants
from other universities
that are doing exactly that number two
what is the difference between
three and six months program the
difference is that
if you are wanting to actually publish
it takes a long time and so even though
we know you can do a lot in three months
we would like you to understand that it
is a time consuming process
and i will talk a little bit about the
process
so that you really understand what is
the time commitment that is needed
so how many hours commitment does the
research fellowship require
so the research fellowship is flexible
and is highly dependent on your
commitment
personally if you want to get the most
out of this we recommend spending at
least
10 to 15 hours per week on
your research project which includes
just
one to two hours for a weekly meeting
it also includes about an hour a day
to go through the different learning
materials that are needed
so remember i said in total 15 10 to 15
hours
so if you just spend one hour a day
that's seven hours
plus about two to three hours per week
for interaction with your mentor and
with the whole group so that's about 10
hours
some people need more than an hour they
also need additional time to do
literature review
and perform their own analysis so that's
why we estimate it to be between 10
and 15 hours per week what are the
mentorship options
so i will go through some of the
mentorship options you can use
our team as your mentors but also we'll
introduce you to some of the
advanced mentorship options that you can
choose from
can we choose any topic yes you can find
a topic that we will help you
identify you can refine that topic
during your interaction with the mentor
and then you can develop a full research
proposal around that topic
can you work in group projects yes you
can the way to work in group projects is
to communicate with your mentor
and bring together that team or ask for
an
introduction so we can definitely help
you with that
can you publish yes and we have some
examples that i will show you in a few
minutes
and then finally pricing payment options
and scholarships and so i will get to
that
just let me give a little bit more
detail about some of these first
questions so first of all
here's an example uh here's an
example of a research project
and i want to briefly talk about how do
you get from
a topic that seems interesting to
actually
finishing that project and submitting it
as a publication this is an example
from one of our programs with university
of ghana
where we had a whole lab join this
project
and bring their own data to complete
some number of publications in six
months
so during the six months we first of all
helped design
different project ideas and turn them
into bioinformatics research
that has some additional competitiveness
to it by including
methods of analysis that previously the
lab was not exposed to
so then we refined those proposals
and going through several internal
presentations
created posters and this is an example
of a poster that we
presented together with the team at one
of the research conferences
during that time we got some feedback
and now we are working on turning that
feedback into a full
journal present journal publication for
peer review
so that whole process takes at least six
months right
but in the process a lot has been
achieved in three months
and so here are some examples of people
that just did three months
and what are the outcomes for them so
one of our graduates is
urja park who in the course of three
months
submitted a project did her presentation
at different conferences
but also developed a full publication
that
later on was submitted to bioarchive
andres is a high school student that
completed
his training developed a research
proposal
and now is going for a competition that
he is going to
participate in here's another
participant that actually used his
experience
to participate in a hackathon and then
went on to
receive prizes during a hackathon and
also we
have others that have participated in
these and
actually uh got into other types of
programs
as a result of their experience so
really those are the different outcomes
you can
do a poster presentation you can join a
competition
you can also get prizes from different
competitions because of the training
or you might be going for a phd or a
master's program so it's going to be
easier for you to get accepted
if you show that you have the necessary
background
okay so as i mentioned some of the
outcomes could be certificates in
different presentations that you do
or even submission a of a pre-print
like you see right here others have
also went on to publish for example
uh semai delano here um actually
submitted her
uh uh to a publication
uh on in the columbia undergraduate
science journal
and so there's a publication option but
of course we cannot guarantee that we
can only guarantee that we will help you
but you will have to go for an actual
publication so this is the publication
that she got
others actually use this in their phd
programs so for example olgo dartsva
she's a research affiliate postdoc at
roswell park comprehensive cancer center
and as a result of her training she was
able to apply the same methods to her
research both pre-clinical
and ideas about clinical research
another student
a phd student at louisiana state
university
went through the coursework as a part of
her university requirements
if you are a high school student we also
have a number of high school students
that have participated
in the different programs that we have
and actually designed
a project as you can see right here to
get some
awards at a science fair
here's an example of a student from
georgetown university
systems medicine master degree program
so especially if you are interested
in applying to different uh programs
at universities this is relevant as well
uh you can get a lot of benefit by
learning
additional information about the new
topics like machine learning
here's another phd student that we have
had previously in a program so actually
as a part of his thesis
he used the program to work on his
thesis
and interact with the mentors okay
number two i see a lot of questions that
come up
about mentorship so for the summer
we have a great panel of expert mentors
that
have phds in relevant fields
that have mastered degrees in relevant
fields and that are
very interested to work with students
not only can you work on an
independent project you can also
get their guidance on projects that are
impactful from their perspective right
and this is critical because
they are already working on important
research topics
and they can get you involved in those
projects
so beyond just working independently you
can actually
know what it's like to work in a high
level expert lab
guided by a mentor that is already
accomplished that has the publications
that can actually guide you through the
steps that they have been through
and so dr harpreet ka or has numerous
publications in bioinformatics and
cancer
dr sona vasudevan is a professor and
program director and expert in systems
medicine
clinton cunha has a master's degree in
molecular medicine and a master's degree
in bioinformatics
uh dr geo chavis has a phd in
bioinformatics and an
expert in neurodegenerative diseases and
glioblastoma
sahil sathya is a phd student in
bioinformatics big data
and is working on covet and health
disparities
and dr laura harris is a program
director and has a phd in bioinformatics
and is an expert in microbiology and we
have others in our network as well
so to gain that high level expertise
you can also design a proposal get
feedback from them but also then have
their guidance on how to make the most
out of your proposal
and when i say we have a broader network
we have been working with a number of
very experienced
uh ex with high level experts in
different domains
that have evaluated our approach in our
system
and they could also be an example and
potentially
guide you if we find the appropriate fit
so what are these resources that can
help you
get into the program and understand how
it works
before you commit let me ask you
um at this time to uh
go to our portal and uh i want to kind
of show you around
on how you can get started with this
process okay
so the first thing that we want to do is
we want to go to
learn.omicslogic.com and i will briefly
introduce you
to some of the topics that are covered
and where you can find them
okay so let me take a pause here
this is the this is the address
again let's open this link together
okay once you are here
on the top you will see the button
to log in
okay so when you log in
you will be taken to the sign up page
and on the sign up page you just either
if you already have an account uh you
can log
in if you don't have an account just yet
you have to sign up
okay so please let me know when you're
there
okay so i see some people are right now
logging in
or creating an account sorry
okay see anita
all right let me know once you're logged
in by putting yes or number one
in the chat
all right thank you
okay uh thank you navia okay so i see
uh praveen is asking uh for a number
okay so i see more people signing up
great i'll give it a moment for
everybody to be able to log
in so again if you are not logged in you
click right here on create an account
and if you are logged in you can just
use your email that you have saved
all right great so i see more signing up
excellent
okay so once you are in
i want to shortly
look at your profile okay so the way
so if you could also
just help others that cannot log in
or provide your phone number potentially
for those that need help
okay it looks like praveen is asking for
someone
all right excellent so i see about 50 of
you are signed in right now
um i'll give it another 20 seconds
for everybody to finish all right great
so
all right 10 11 all right excellent
zubash thank you
once you are logged in please let me
know and if you
are logged in then on the top menu
you will see this link right here
and you can go to your profile
alright excellent okay so once you're in
your profile
you will see that you can fill out your
profile right here by clicking on the
profile
here you will see your points this is an
important part of making progress and
staying consistent
you can see that your mentor is actually
going to be looking
at your progress every week
to determine how much you have made
progress
and help you where you are struggling so
this is an important way
to show how you are doing in this
program
the second thing that i want to show you
are the courses
so here you will see the courses that
you have started so let's take a look
a little bit about the courses
so right here we have the course tab
and on the courses i recommend everyone
just i'll briefly show you for those
that are new to bioinformatics
you can find a course called bytes and
molecules
in this bison molecules course you will
find some introductory materials that
are completely free
okay so here you will find some free
lessons
and one paid lesson that is optional
but this is to really get you started
with the terminology and the concepts
and the different things that
are needed in this
field of omics and in this field of
computational biology
another free course that you can get
started with and i recommend for all of
you that are new
to the platform and new to
bioinformatics
is introduction to bioinformatics so
very short course
but importantly in this lesson
it starts off with a survey that helps
us refine our materials
and learn about you because our
objective here is not only to
provide you with the training and guide
you but we cannot guide you if we don't
know about you
okay so please take a look here
and jamari by the way i will address
your question in just a moment
so after the courses the other thing
that they want to point your
attention to are the programs so here
we're talking about the research
fellowship program
but we have other very affordable
programs or more advanced
programs guided by experts in the field
and so i recommend that you take a look
at some of these programs as well
if you see a program that has started a
while back you can still join because
you will get access
to the recordings of the sessions as
well
maybe i can show you how that works
this is an ongoing program called lbrn
omixlogic data science
if you are not vlog if you're not a part
of this program you'll see a different
screen
but here you can see how the sessions
are being recorded and shared right here
you have a full schedule but you can
access
all of the previous sessions as well
okay and so down here below you also
have access to a synchronous coursework
and that asynchronous coursework
supplements the in-person sessions that
we have
and at the end after you have completed
all of the sessions
you will get a certificate of completion
right here
so that's the second one and and then
finally
we have the research fellowship and as i
mentioned the research fellowship is
structured
around submitting a project
and so how does that work courses
we talked about courses programs
we talked about programs and now let's
talk about
projects so after you have
went through the steps to gain 10 000
points
to complete your profile and complete a
course
on how to design your project you can
start a new project
and when you start a new project it will
give you
a very guided process on how you can go
from the title and the abstract all the
way
to what could be reproduced by somebody
else
and evaluated by an expert which is
really the goal of this whole program
and fellowship so in the beginning
you go through training then you can
join
an expert guided program and at the end
submit your own independent project okay
now importantly many of the people that
join
are struggling with access to tools
that need a lot of computational power
and so that is why our team is
leveraging
a big data analysis platform
that has machine learning that has
different processing tools different
visualization tools
and so if you come across a project that
has thousands of samples
and a lot of data in them this is the
solution you can get
unstuck and go beyond what you would
typically be able to do on your own
laptop
by leveraging this big data server where
you have
over five terabytes of space that you
can leverage
during this training and during this
program
okay so finally let me just briefly
explain
how to join the program and what you can
expect from the three months option or
the six
months option so here is
the link sorry here's the link let me go
back
so the link to register for the research
fellowship is right here
and i'll briefly explain the different
options
okay so first of all there are three
months
or six months we recommend for people
that already have a topic in mind
you're working on a project or you want
to work on a project and you know what
that project is
to go for the three months option we
recommend this to people that
already have some background in
bioinformatics and already know how to
use some of the tools
if you're just getting started but you
do want to get to a publication
it typically will take longer time so
you can try the three months option and
then extend it
but we really recommend the six months
option
now i will tell you a little bit about
the pricing but i do want you to know
that there
is a process to get a scholarship the
process of the scholarship
requires for you to provide a
justification
on why this price is too expensive and
you need financial aid
and then provide some references from
your current faculty
or people that can recommend your
ability to learn and complete a project
on time
and we will reach out to them so that we
can
make sure that after receiving the
scholarship
you will be successful in the program so
you have the time
you have the commitment and you have the
perseverance to go through all of the
required steps
what are the pricing options so here are
the pricing options for three months
here are the pricing options for six
months
for three months there's a beginner and
an advanced option
and basically this means that either you
have access to
all of the things that we discussed
except for
you are not planning to do extensive
research so you're only going to use
this
to learn interact with others and get a
research proposal
if you actually want to conduct the
research and utilize the big data server
you should opt for the advanced option
for six months it is essentially double
the price
right because it's just six months and
it's longer
okay and i recommend checking out all of
these details on this page
so so now jaspee if you could please
share the links
including the blog post link now that
would be great
at the end you will get a certificate
and so if you need
a letter of recommendation if you need
feedback from an expert
if you need some kind of interaction to
with your university
we are set up to do that so you can
reach out to the mentors
and the support team and they will help
you with those documents as well
okay so for those of you that actually
are wondering what next so let's say i
joined the fellowship
let's say i can do this and let's say
i want some you know go beyond i want to
join
a master's degree or a phd program maybe
i'm opting for a program
in the u.s maybe i'm interested to
work on a research project with others
what do i do next
so the next thing that i want to briefly
introduce today
is the omics research symposium okay
so after you are a participant in
any of the programs on omixlogic we
invite you to join the omix research
symposium
and participate in the discussions about
cutting-edge bioinformatics
how to join different programs get
prizes and
also get feedback from expert judges
so if you could please also share the
link
to the august symposium
somalicano just me so after
you are welcome to take a look at this
symposium now the symposium is going to
start on august 21st and 22nd
we have a lineup of great speakers
including
dr sona vasudevan who is the director of
the georgetown university master's
degree program in systems medicine
dr gus casullas who repre who is the
president of the national association of
idea principal investigators but also
the head of the department at louisiana
state university
in virology and biotechnology dr
lena brodsky who is the director of the
talbot bioinformatics research center
at university of haiti venezuela
dr philip compil who is the assistant
department
head at carnegie mellon university
dr chris taylor who is the director of
the louisiana biomedical research
network
bioinformatics corps and is a professor
at louisiana state university health
sciences center
okay what are they going to be talking
about they will discuss
bioinformatics cutting edge research and
applications in bioinformatics
where is this field going we're going to
be talking about single cell
multiomics integration quantum computing
machine learning and artificial
intelligence translational
bioinformatics how is it used in
clinical research
clinical data integration how are
pharmaceutical companies using
bioinformatics today
we will introduce undergraduate masters
and phd programs in bioinformatics
at university of haifa at university at
georgetown university
at carnegie mellon university at
louisiana state university
at louisiana state university health
sciences center and others
we will also have recruiters that will
speak to you about
industry internships and job
opportunities using bioinformatics so if
you do want to
get an internship remotely or in person
if you would like to explore
what does a career in bioinformatics
really look like you will get a chance
to interact with those people as well
you will find effective resources for
training and education so we will
present case studies around
outcomes from training so bioinformatics
is a challenging field
not only is it something that takes a
lot of time but it's a challenging field
and so we will talk about that as well
and we will have prizes for best
school college and citizen science
research project so
if you have a project and you still have
time
you have about a month to submit and
potentially get a price for the best
presentation or at least get recognition
so everybody that joins the competition
will have a certificate for joining and
participating in the competition
for those of you that will win the price
it will be a monetary price so you can
use that money
buy a new laptop or even uh you know
take a break from work for a while so
this is something that i'm
really excited and looking forward to
okay so
finally i want to mention that what we
talked about today
is not just paid programs and coursework
and joining our portal and things like
that we also want to interact with you
and we have some
groups on social media where we have a
lot of these contacts
and we regularly share opportunities
from us but also from others
and so we welcome you to join our social
media group on linkedin
and on facebook would you ask me if you
could please share those links
we welcome you to join uh you will learn
about
upcoming opportunities and you will also
hear from experts
that discuss important links and
important topics there
okay that's the linkedin group and
please adjust we also share the facebook
group link
we do a lot of webinars and those
webinars are
posted on our youtube channel so today
uh
uh already sonalika made this stream
live on youtube but you will find a lot
of
other resources on the youtube link
so this is the live stream and so nalika
please
share the link to the channel or just we
were still waiting for the link for
facebook
okay so now i would like to pass it back
to sonalika
to uh introduce uh ruthvi
and navi if they're available
thank you so much elia here in the group
i have shared the link to our youtube
channel and you can find
a lot of videos there explaining uh
different sorts of
uh domains which we are working on uh
for bioinformatics
now i would want to invite ruthvi to
talk about
her submission as a poster presentation
in one of the conferences and also talk
about her psionics club
and she would be presenting tomorrow so
i would want her to talk about that as
well over to you
suite
hi everyone and a very good evening to
all of you
uh to begin with my journey uh with find
biotech
firstly i am an undergraduate biomedical
sciences student
so when i was in my first year i joined
fine biotech
with almost zero knowledge of
bioinformatics
uh i literally didn't know what data
sets
meant what is ncbi nothing i mean you
understand what i mean by saying
zero so i joined initially it's almost
an year i'm associated with fine biotech
and i'm very happy for that
so uh i joined as a growth ambassador
initially
and as an ambassador i was given several
tasks and
at that time i went through the portal
of find biotech and learn
all the omics courses in which i had to
give exams of
you know all the small small self
assessment courses
later on i went and developed a student
community club under pine biotic that is
named as psionics
i am currently the president of cyanomix
and we have
two to three sessions every month that
is every thursday
on certain topics of bioinformatics
like we have how to do a literature
review that i am doing tomorrow
we also have expertise talks we also
have
interviews and pres presentation of
projects by phd students or
undergraduates or graduate students
so later on near december i started this
cyanics club
and when i was ready knowing all the
knowledge not all but
basic knowledge of bioinformatics my
mentors said that i was ready to apply
that knowledge to a real project
so i was always interested in
neuro-informatics
so my area of interest was
neurodegenerative disorder
so i chose multiple sclerosis as my
disease of interest
i found a data set and later on went
ahead
and developed my own project so i worked
on this project for nearly three months
under the expert guidance of ilya dr
harpreet and dr mohit mazumdar
so later on after completing my project
i'm still in the process of
submitting my research paper
so my mentors have really helped me to
edit and you know justify my mistake
organize the structure of my research
paper
but before the research paper comes out
i went ahead
and made my own poster and i decided to
present it to the upcoming conferences
so last week i presented my this poster
on the
medicinal conference 2021 and i won the
second prize for the best poster
research poster category
so it has really helped me a lot
so from growing from level zero to a
greater level applying big data analysis
and my mentors over here have really
really supported me
not just for the project but they also
supported me in networking i have
significantly grown in terms of
communication networking talking with
experts and everything
and so yeah i won the second prize and
i'm looking forward to my next
conference presentation
and i also submitted my this project to
international society for computational
biology of which i'm presenting this
friday that is 23rd
so i'm looking forward and i would
really recommend
to anyone who want to learn about dry
lab and data analysis
to enter this fellowship and really give
it a try because
once you enter you will get to know that
how much it was worth it
and i'm always thankful for my mentors
so thank you so much
uh what about the psionics club routine
tomorrow's meeting
yeah correct so tomorrow for uh is
thursday as i said we have ceramic
sessions every thursday so tomorrow we
have a group of students
on some members in ceramics club who are
interested
in knowing about how to conduct a
literature review and how to go on
further to write a review paper or
research paper
so tomorrow in the ceramics club the
theme of the session is how to do a
literature review
so i would be giving you a detailed uh
description of
how to do a literature review because i
have been through those stages and there
would be
other mentors also to guide you so as a
student i can
show it better to you that what
difficulties you would face as a starter
as a first-time person who receiving a
literature review
so i warmly invite you all to tomorrow's
session of cyanomix club at 6 pm ist
also if you want to join the club all
the links would be available
in the description box so just we have
already shared it thank you hsp
we daily update everything like the
sessions going on the upcoming events
and everything in the ceramics look
so i hope to see you all there as well
thank you
thank you so much ruthvi now i would
like to invite
navya for sharing her experience with us
over to young
okay navia i'll just check
hi everybody yeah so i'm a research
favorite buying biotech
i basically joined pine biotech about a
month ago
and i'm new to the field of
bioinformatics and i didn't really know
much about the subject
and since we're having online classes
from college i couldn't get any
practical knowledge or hands-on
experience for that matter
so in order to have wider perspective
and practical knowledge about the
subject i joined fine biotech
and my journey so far has been
flourishing i am now familiar with
so many new techniques and technology
and of course they're working
that i didn't even know existed a month
back i've had tremendous growth in this
short span of time and i'm really
looking forward to learn more and
obviously it has all been possible
because of the extraordinary guidance of
my mentors dr mohit dr harpietka
and our very own ceo india so thank you
this wouldn't have been possible without
your help
thank you so much navia for sharing your
experience with us
now i would want to invite our mentor dr
harpreet
kaur to introduce herself and guide the
research fellows over to you dr halperi
thank you sonalika just let me share my
screen
hello everyone my name is harpreet kaur
i have a phd in bioinformatics in my
current role
i am curricular doctor and research
consultant with pine biotech
my major research interest lies in the
area of the application of the
bioinformatics
in oncology besides the oncology
infectious disease and neuroscience are
my other
research areas so i am one of the
mentor for this research fellowship
program i am involved in designing
research process
and assisting research fellows in their
project design
and analysis
now let me give you the glimpse of some
uh
how bioinformatics can be helpful in
identifying
importance this is signature by taking
some example
for my doctoral research work
so here in the first project we use
large-scale transcriptomic stata which
is publicly available
on different public repositories to
identify
diagnostic biomarker panels for primary
liver cancer which is
hepatocellular carcinoma so here in the
study we employed 30 datasets which
containing nearly 4 000 samples to
elicit a transcriptomic biomarker panel
for the diagnosis
and the prognosis of the liver cancer
implementing various bioinformatics
techniques
in the second project we employed nine
data set which containing
350 clean geocarcinoma 130
or nearly 130 edges in non-tumorous
tissue samples
and 90 hepatocellular carcinoma sample
to scrutinize cleanse your carcinoma
specific transcriptomic signatures
uh for by implementing number of the
data mining techniques
like extra tree svm render forest
logistic regression etc
so in the third project we use
transcriptomics
and methylation data to identify a
biomarker
panel for the stage classification of
hepatocellular carcinoma
so for this project we use tcpa data of
nearly 350 tissue samples and elucidate
51 features
are as key signatures that can predict
scc at an early stage
so in my current role i am i am research
consultant
and i'm mentoring number of the research
follows
so as uh i have also mentioned one of
the research follow
uh ms dulana whose undergraduate
student from turkey recently completed
her research project entitled long
non-coding rnas
as therapeutic target in chronic
lymphocytic
leukemia using publicly available
data and implementing various
bioinformatics tools which are
integrated on
t band for server and this work is
published in
already a columbia university journal
so then miss ujja parikh who is a
postgraduate student
and she has completed her research
project on
identification of the biomarker to
differentiate between neural stem cells
and glioblastoma some
uh trioblastoma stem cells using
publicly
available ngos data for the glioblastoma
implementing various bioinformatics
techniques
so apart from that then there is another
research fellow
miss de lara dickens who is a master
student from the turkey
she completed her metagenomics project
on space radiation
so apart from the graduate masters and
phd students
i also got the opportunity to mentor
number of the high school students
so one of uh the project fellow
uh nitra mr nehra siriniwasan who is a
high school student in the usa
completed her project on the effect of
the menstrual cycle at transcriptional
label
so next another research fellow mr
anders
who is a high school student is he is
also able to complete his project on the
alzheimer's
so as i already told you my major
research interest lies
in the application of the bioinformatics
in various human health aspects
but my primary research area is cancer
genomics
and apart from that neuroscience and
infectious disease are other other
research areas
and i'm looking forward uh to being your
mentor in
this comic logic research fellowship
program
now i would like pass this session back
to miss sonalika
to talk about registration and the rest
of the process
so over to you miss analika
thank you so much dr harpreet i would
want to invite dr
mohit to discuss about the registration
process
as we see that there are many
participants who are not clear with the
the with the registration process so dr
mohit would be explaining it to
you over to your doctor
okay thank you hello everyone so the
registration process is
pretty simple and straightforward so
with this fellowship
program you will have an opportunity to
discuss your project and work on your
project use the course material and also
access the tbi info server and one of
the things that we have not discussed
uh clearly is that that these are the
license that are
uh been uh provided to you during this
entire period of this fellowship which
is for three months
so to cover those uh there is a
subscription
fees for the program to join and i think
we have shared the link
with you here and maybe once again
if anyone can share the link um or just
we
to the program page where one can
subscribe for the program
for three months so if you're planning
to join and start working on your
project
uh you can subscribe to the program and
we'll start
by conducting an orientation session
followed by
guiding you through the resources so we
also have prepared asynchronous material
and
emails from where you will get all the
information
and also you will be able to you know
interact with us
through various channels like slack
and also skype and as well as all the
other social media handles that we just
shared
and i'll be happy to take any more
questions if you have regarding anything
that we discussed today
okay so if we have no more questions uh
you can email us at
uh marketing at the pine dot bio or
marketing at the rate omislogic.com
so we have one question from subha he's
asking do we need a research topic on
our own to start and get
into the fellowship program
so the research fellowship works for
different uh
students coming from different
backgrounds students coming from
different backgrounds also faculties are
joining this research fellowship program
to help work on their projects so it
depends uh
subhash if you already have a research
topic that you are interested in
and a specific disease area that you are
interested in for example
if you are interested in infectious
diseases if you are interested in cancer
or if you are interested in neuroscience
or if you're interested in agriculture
so those are the area of interest that
we would want you to
you know explore more after learning
about your research interest
so we kind of help in both ways so we
have different project
examples first for you to learn from so
you do the courses which have
and hands-on uh part where you do the
assignments and go through the data sets
and then
you learn about these example projects
that we have put together for example
star school 2 covet 19
and breast cancer cell line project
mouse pdx breast cancer projects so
these are different
project examples and there are many uh
to go through or
if you have not uh figured out your
research
project or research idea so you can
develop that research idea
or you can work on your research idea
that you have already developed so both
the options are there
uh which actually we guide them through
the material
that helps you develop that sort of
strategy to be able to come up with a
research proposal
so it's a standard method and we have
also a course
just to describe this entire process
thank you so much sir and answering your
question
uh yes you can uh like your mentor can
help you with the with the research
question if you have no
idea so in the beginning of the research
fellowship program you would be asked to
go through the
asynchronous course material according
to your research and trust
and then your mentor would also uh help
you go through the literature like they
would suggest you with the literature if
you're not able to find any
and then you are supposed to submit your
research proposal and
mentor would be there always to help you
with each and every step to modify your
proposal question as well
so you ha you need not worry about
anything
your mentor would be there to guide you
at each and every step
there are some more questions which i
would want to answer sunalika
so there is one question from siddhartha
i'm currently in
uh dui in msc integrated course for
bionic
bioanalytical sciences it is is it
possible to get a subscription for the
program in the future
so yes actually you can join this
program anytime and we kind of recommend
you to
maybe start with the asynchronous
material when you have time
like it's like you can do it at your
luxury
because you will have a subscription for
ma for a month at a very low cost
uh so the subscription is like ten
dollars and you can start going through
the materials that we just discussed on
your own
so once you're more prepared you can
come up with research proposal when you
like when you have time for to join a
dedicated mentor guided program
so if you're not ready right now for a
mentor guided program i recommend you to
go to the go through the asynchronous
material that will actually help you
develop that project that you would want
to work on so
um i think uh again if you would want to
it's a rolling circle
a rolling basis
participation in this program for you to
participate you can join this program
anytime
as i said there will be an orientation
orientation session and then you will be
able to join these group sessions
where we discuss about your project and
there is a weekly
report that you will have to submit and
while you go through the resources and
the tasks
and that we have assigned you based on
your progress
so that's how it works and for the
question that
i have from shiv so can
we do a research that our mentor wants
and i would also like to ask siddhartha
if i could i have answered his questions
so yes there are free courses also so i
saw another question from
you so so yes there are free courses for
you to start with which is bytes and the
molecules which was shown in this
presentation and also
the shared link and once you log in to
learn you can search for
bytes and molecule course and
introduction to bioinformatics course
all those courses
are free which helps you actually
develop an
idea about which research area you wrote
you would want to explore more
now uh coming back to the question that
shiv asked
can we do a research that our mentor
wants so actually it's
let me reframe this so we have already
quite a few ongoing projects
and we there is an opportunity to do
group group projects also not just
individual projects
so we have scientists like uh elias
showed that we have a group of
scientists who are working on their
research projects from
university of ghana naguchi
and also we have several other people uh
researchers faculties
join our research projects and they
would want maybe some assistance from
you to do work on a specific area and
generate some data
and work on maybe the thesis or the
project so there are several
opportunities like this to work on a
group project and even
within your network you can ask your
friends to join the research fellowship
and work on a group
project and that would be like we kind
of recommend that
because in very short period of time
you'll be able to
like if a lot of people are working on
the same problem so
it actually helps the project to grow in
several direction and be more
translational
as well
thank you so much dr mohit and thank you
so much everyone
for joining i am again dropping our mail
ids here marketing at the eight pine dot
bio and also you can reach our doctor
mohit at mohit adhrai pine dot
bio and i would uh like to request you
all to please add us to your address
book so that you don't miss out on any
of the important updates
thank you for joining we hope to meet
you soon again bye